Oh hello there, everybody! I would like to thank all you ice cream truck drivers out there.
Who are the ice cream truck drivers?
Those are the folks that deliver that freaking ice cream straight into your freaking ear holes.
Right now I'd like to...
The average internet home. It's, well, pretty average.
It's where award-winning dramas get dinged for frequent buffering.
Some talented racers lag off the track.
And that next promotion goes to the person not breaking up on the call.
So don't be an average internet home. Be a Gateway Fiber home.
With super-fast speeds, you'll catch all of that epic monologue,
race with a permanent power-up, and present so everyone can hear you.
Unless you're on mute.
Check availability at gatewayfiber.com and make the move.
And don't forget about your first month free.
I'd like to thank Richard Dunn, Sarah Boyle, Sax Guy Jimmy D, Scoop,
Scoop Brady, Scoop Dijor, Scoop Kada, Scoopy Kyae Motherfucker,
Thunder Cougar Falcon Scoop, and Travis Chiguri.
Oh, God damn it!
Slippy Kyae Motherfucker made me say "motherfucker" instead of "motherfricker."
Now we've been demonetized.
Right. It doesn't even matter now. It's all over.
Oh, no!
If you want to be an ice cream truck driver,
come help us because we've just been demonetized from this YouTube stream
because of Thunder Cougar Falcon Scoop and Slippy Kyae Motherfucker.
Come on over, be an ice cream truck driver, preachingfun.com, who knows?
The life you save may be your own.
Here's the show.
Hey, Johnny. Do you want to go to an ice cream social?
Yeah, I'd love to.
Great. Let's go.
I don't know how I made it the first 45 years of my life without jabbing sunblock directly into my eyeball.
But for some reason I have a problem where I keep putting sunblock in my eye.
And then I'm like, fuck, for like hours.
For hours? It's time for Matt Donnelly's Ice Cream Social.
Sitting in Las Vegas, that's Matt Donnelly.
Sitting in Pittsburgh, that's Paul Mattingly.
Also in Las Vegas, it's me, Jacob the Audio Guy.
We're preaching fun.
Yeah. What's up, fools?
Are we on Twitch? People are saying we're not doing Twitch, blah, blah, blah.
Oh, are we not on Twitch? I'll try and put us on Twitch again.
Are we not on Twitch?
I think we're on Twitch now. Maybe we weren't a minute ago.
Okay, well...
Ah, yes, that is true. We are now on Twitch. Hello, Twitch!
And a ranch slug, if you're asking, it is from a man finishing in my eye at a truck stop.
Oh my god, a Finnish man?
A Finnish man finishing.
Yeah. I was like, do any of you speak Finnish?
You? Great. Get in the shower.
So, 50 sunblock. So sunblock, you know, whether it's 20, 30, 50, whatever the SPF.
50 is your go-to SPF?
Alright.
Because I'm a porcelain-skinned beauty.
And for those of us not familiar, what does SPF stand for?
Social Proof Functions.
That's right. Social Proof Functions. No one wins when they wear sunscreen.
And so, but the SPF, the higher the number, it just is the more this stuff takes longer to break down in your skin.
That's the only thing. It's like, whatever's mixed with the sunblock, it's mixed with the substance that slowly goes into your skin, slowly but surely.
So when I try to protect this beautiful moneymaker right here, the face for audio that you're listening to right now...
You can't see it if you're just listening to the show. Matt just pointed at his ass.
He pointed at his beautiful white ass.
Now, I've learned my lesson.
His alabaster white.
I ruined our interview with Colin Cloud by being a weird mess the entire time with my eyeball the entire time.
Right? That's the most embarrassing interview we've had.
Somehow Colin and I are still... No, no, no. There were more embarrassing interviews.
We're still nice to each other, but we would have been closer had it been a normal person on that podcast. We would be friends.
Fair, fair.
But, so...
He did actually, Colin and I had lunch yesterday and he said, "What the fuck is up with Matt's eyes?"
You're like, "Oh no, he's on a real streak. Nothing. Nothing. He's been on a roll."
Actually, that's not true. We don't talk about you because it puts a weird damper on our relationship.
And so I put it in my eye and then once it starts singing I go, "Oh shit, I messed up again."
And I know it's going to be like this way for the afternoon because it takes that long for 50 SPF to absorb.
That's the whole idea.
This is how I live now.
I can't make it go away.
But I did that because I went over to my kid's fun run.
So we started our recording an hour later today so I could be there for my child.
Stop your angry emails.
You and your paternal responsibilities.
My child comes first.
That's what my wife keeps telling me.
You don't have a child.
No, but she says she comes first.
Uh oh.
Oh, I thought she was telling you that Matt's children came first.
As a rule, if you do first then she's mad?
No, no, in marital affair times, in snuggle times, wife comes first.
And I agree.
So I go over there.
Now the fun run, there's a few scoops who are very generous to donate to my channel's campaign.
If they haven't already, they'll get a cute little thank you video for it.
If you haven't gotten your thank you video and you think you're owed one, email me at matt@hayscoops.com.
Don't do that if you're in the chat.
You've got to give me the weekend.
But this comes out on Monday.
So if you haven't gotten it by Monday, I should have gotten you a goddamn video.
We do indeed have a wonderful, generous community.
And it's all to go to this fun run, right?
And so this fun run raises funds for the schools while this company makes money putting it on, right?
So I just found out today that the school doesn't get all the money.
I always thought the funding was put on by the school.
It's put on a company that runs it.
Oh, boy.
What is there to run?
So they show up.
They have prizes for individuals who raise a certain amount of money, right?
And that's when my kid's trying to get this annoying beach ball to annoy his mom.
That's his campaign.
And they also come with all these accoutrements.
When the kids do this actual run on the school, there's like a water squirting tunnel.
There's like different obstacles.
There's like a big foam machine.
I think they give out all these water pistol cannons to the teachers for the kids.
It's this big outdoor event, right?
Okay.
I thought all this stuff belonged to the school and I was wrong.
Now, I get it's not -- I get like someone probably did run it for a school one year.
And like someone said, we should do this for all the schools.
Yeah.
And then it becomes a business and the business has costs and blah, blah, blah.
Yeah, sure.
So they don't get all the dough.
But so if they got to -- they raised $50,000 for the school, which is probably $25,000
or something after the company gets cut.
After they get their feet wet.
They take half.
Good Lord.
They probably do.
And I was like, is it capped?
Because if we go over a certain amount, all that money should go to the school.
Once you make enough to go through the fun run, you should be calling it.
But I'm not on the PTA and I'm not about to join the PTA for this issue.
Matt Donnelly, PTA president.
So the goal was to get the $50,000 for the school, you know, five or six grades altogether,
raising 50 grand.
They -- the science teacher is going to shave his head for the whole school.
Oh, boy.
The kids would go crazy for the shaving of heads.
Right.
That translates.
That has been a time honored tradition.
That's always been a big thing with wrestling back in the day.
They don't do it anymore.
I haven't seen them do it in like, I don't know, a long time.
But that used to be a big thing.
I just saw a fun interview, a fun wrestling interview this week with -- who was the -- I know his name.
The Olympic guy who was with WWF for a long time.
Kurt Angle.
He was talking about a match that he had had with another wrestler who I didn't recognize, I don't think.
But apparently, this other wrestler had really long, flowing hair.
And Kurt Angle said, "Vince McMahon came to me and said, 'Hey, you're losing your hair.
Let's do a match where you get your head shaved at the end of it.
But don't tell the other guy, because I'm going to tell him that he has to shave his head.'"
Oh.
That's pretty slick, actually.
And they just played a joke on this other guy until the day of.
And they were like, "No, no, no. You're going to win. You're going to shave his head."
Hilarious.
Pretty slick.
Well, Vince McMahon is such a cut up.
What a card.
Really makes you appreciate Vince McMahon's sense of humor.
I think maybe I was wrong about him.
Exactly.
Good dude.
He's just a scamp.
Misunderstood.
Union busting and sexual predator aside, good dude.
Yeah, yeah.
I wonder if he has any spouses that could run things on a federal level.
I bet he does.
Let's try.
You know, a woman who's an entertainer and a magician in town.
Stacy Stardust, our friend Stacy Stardust.
Oh yeah.
We like Stacy.
She's one of the people that puts a lot of motivational stuff up on her Instagram feed all the time.
Gotcha.
And so I had this really heartfelt rallying speech by Dana White.
And I was like, Dana White straight up hit a woman at a party like in front of everyone.
Yeah, he slapped his wife at the slap preview.
He was at the event to preview the slap competition stuff, and he just slapped his wife.
And I was like, if you want to privately be inspired by Dana White, you go right ahead.
As any entertainer, I don't want to put anything up with Dana White.
But as a woman entertainer, you want to be like, see this woman slapper?
You can learn from him.
This woman slapper.
Don't forget our favorite NFL player, Ray Rice.
Come on, Ray.
Oh my god.
So they hit the $50,000 goal to shave the guy's head.
They did it.
They had a couple more days.
And so what they want to do is they want to add stretch goals.
Right?
Ah, OK, good.
Bubes?
Is he going street legal?
No, no, no.
They upgrade, instead of shaving, they upgrade to Nair water cannons.
What?
Oh, god.
They just braid every hair off of him.
Oh, Jesus.
Nair pressure washing.
He's just going to look like one of those Mr. Bigglesworth true cats.
He's going to be fucked.
Good god.
No, no, no.
No, we get an email from the principal saying that if we reach $55,000.
OK.
The principal and vice principal, we will dress up like babies for a day.
Did you tell them that we tried that and it didn't work?
I was like, can I show you this Whistling Weirdos video from the Gong show?
No, I was literally like, dress up like babies?
Like what?
Why are you trying to be all sexy?
Like, no, don't make me dress up like a baby.
Don't raise so much money, I got to dress like a baby.
No.
Where would I ever find a pacifier in this bottle I could drink out of?
What?
No.
How will I find the time to go out to my car and get my baby out and fit?
It's not Saturday.
But I definitely don't always have it in my car with me.
And if we get to $60,000, I'll fill my diaper.
Don't make me do it.
Don't make me shit publicly.
Don't make me publicly shit in a diaper.
I'll be so embarrassed.
What will I do?
I'll never be able to show my sexy face again.
I probably won't even be able to masturbate properly.
No, I will.
I'll find a way.
If it's $65, you can discipline me for a dirty diaper by putting this dog leash on me.
Oh my God, right?
It just keeps getting worse.
For $70, you can spit on me.
$70 is the spit level.
All the students at the school can just spit on me for $70,000.
Oh, God.
You made it to spit level, guys.
Yep.
Scoop up Monte Cristo.
Oh, we didn't make our goal, but oops, I'm dressed like a baby anyway.
Sorry.
Aren't I silly?
I'm such a silly goose.
I thought it was baby day.
Oh, boy.
I don't want these two ladies dressed like a baby.
Oh, they're ladies.
Yeah.
I've changed my mind.
You're in.
Paul is now donating to my kids fundraiser.
Yeah, exactly.
Where's that URL?
Hold on.
Paul is now getting him straight to $70,000.
Two lady principals?
Hold on.
Two ladies.
And then there was an established goal for $60,000.
And the same guy who shaved his head was going to dye his eyebrows blue.
And I was like, can we have a meeting about stretch goals?
Can we just-- can we have it up?
Just five minutes.
Five minutes, everybody.
Like, I get it.
You thought 50 grand was shooting for the moon.
You were not prepared.
You were not prepared to go over that goal.
Let's just circle wagons for a sec, and let's just figure some stuff out.
Don't be a baby lady.
We're doing some really weird kinky shit for these stretch goals.
Don't be a lady baby.
We've gone straight to babies.
And I don't think all the children in the movie are like, oh my god, blue eyebrows.
That would be the best.
I will say that eyebrow shaving is, I think for an adult, a bigger deal than head shaving.
It's dangerous because sometimes they don't grow back.
Exactly.
That's not a good idea.
Yeah.
It's a gamble.
And even dying, if you use the wrong kind of dye, you know, it could be bad.
It'll kill you.
You could be stuck putting shit on your eye like I am right now.
That could happen to you.
Matt, are you not able to use spray?
I don't want to spray my eye.
That's where this all started.
But you do it while you have your eyes closed.
You just slightly.
That's what I do.
I use the aerosol.
I know how sunblock works, guy.
Apparently you don't.
I'm sorry to say, Matt.
No, you do not.
There's evidence to the contrary.
There's lots of evidence to the contrary.
You do not know how fucking sunblock works.
You push down and the liquid just comes out like spray?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's aerosolized.
It's great.
No, I do that every time before I mow the lawn.
I hose myself in the face and arms and legs.
Every time before Paul mows the lawn, I hose him in the face.
That's how it works.
And I think about two principals dressed like babies while I do it.
That'll make me spray every time.
I can't stop spraying.
SPLs.
I pre-spray babies.
So much pre-spray.
I do.
I find the spray on my--
There it is.
Scoop a body crystal as your solution.
Yes.
You've got to get this.
I'm not against it.
I'm not with the weird little like suntan booth goggles.
You could just use-- I bet you have goggles.
Don't you have goggles from your kids?
Just some swim goggles.
Yeah, don't you have to destroy your little swim goggles?
I'm just going to put on a scuba mask and I'll just slather around the scuba mask.
I know the scuba mask won't work.
It's too much area covered.
Anyway.
I know.
That's why I'm making that joke.
I know the difference between goggles and a scuba mask.
You should put a bag over your head before you apply your sunscreen.
It won't get in your eyes.
Another person told me to put a bag over my head.
Boy, I got this all the time at Abu Grabe and now here?
Geez.
I've done the spray and I find that the spray when I'm out in the sun for a long time is
not very effective.
Is the spray not very effective or do you touch it?
Well, I spray the other way and I walk into it like perfume.
Paul is not confident in Matt's ability to put on sunscreen at all.
I'm not.
Paul's confidence in Matt's ability to do this on his own is at an all time low.
I've been mowing my lawn in the blazing sun.
Does it not work or do you touch it?
I use a fucking whisper of Aldi brand spray and I'm fine for hours.
And where do you live?
Pennsylvania.
Well.
Okay.
All right.
Hey, hey, hey.
But I did that shit.
I did that shit on the strip promoting as the gazillionaire and I had to spray up there
every day too.
You know who else just had a personal revelation about the sun?
Yeah.
That's the following sponsor.
Today's show, Matt Madigan's Ice Cream Social.
Trust him.
And Who That Baby podcast.
Who That Baby, drop it in the diaper.
Brought to you by, from Coke, Inc.
It's Baroque Coke, soaked, bespoke, smoked oak cloaks.
That's from the Gorilla Dentist from that Björk video in 2025.
I'm sorry.
I looked in the chat and watching the Mace clip of two people spraying each other in the
bathroom.
Exactly how it would be.
Yes, I'm sorry.
That's the Baroque Coke, soaked, bespoke, smoked oak cloaks.
It's a cloak product.
It's a cloak product?
Cloak.
I know it's a cloak, but it's, but it's coke soaked.
That's right.
Okay.
From the Baroque period.
All right.
So here's what I did.
I went to a place that specializes in Baroque art and I stole a cloak from a display of
art that is Baroque.
And then I soaked it in Coke.
And while it was still wet, I had a tailor customize it to me so that it was bespoke.
And then I made sure to smoke it with some essence of oak wood.
So it was oak smoked.
It was an oak smoked Baroque cloak that was bespoke and soaked with Coke.
I don't think you said soaked.
That's all of them.
Was that it?
We checked every box.
I got it.
It's a full commercial.
We nailed it.
It's good to check out.
I'm in the bank.
Now we got to get back to this sunscreen shit.
Do your children burn easily?
Have you taught them how to do it right?
You remember, as long as the podcast will remember, that I had a really great father-son chat.
And then an hour later, we went to put sunblock on and they closed their eyes.
And I did a spray.
I did one and I wasn't quick enough to do the second so that he opened his eyes and
I sprayed him right in the eye.
So this is genetic here.
This is a tradition now.
We're just not meant to be.
We should just go back to cloudy Ireland where our genetics belong.
I see.
Right.
And hide and drink Guinness and tell stories and fight fires.
This is what we should do.
But yeah, finally back to the sunscreen talk.
Yeah.
Anyways.
So I hear you, Paul.
I usually can spray.
No problem.
But I'm in the sun.
I know I'm going to be in the sun for a long time.
You go with the cream.
50 proof SPF so that I don't burn my nose.
Have you thought about going with like those zinc products that are color?
I should have.
I have it.
I know that the mineral ones where I look like a ghost, but it works.
Well, not even that.
Like there's the ones like, remember all the ones that like turn you blue until it, until it sinks in.
The, the, the life guards used to have the blue on their nose.
There's, there's mineral based sunscreens that are maybe way thicker than what you're talking about, but you still have.
I know what you mean.
Yeah.
And they do.
They really do do the job.
They do do.
They do do the job.
They do specifically designed for darker skin.
If I'm not mistaken.
Well, I look legit, there's a legit Irish jeans in terms of that, like skin cancers in my family.
That's why I don't like to rely on the spray.
Oh, you should just stay out of the sun, man.
I try.
What are you doing in Las Vegas?
Matt, Matt, you should get some sunscreen.
I'm getting different, just a different brand sunscreen.
By the way, the thing that frozen custard put in the chat there that like, kind of like that, like it's basically a deodorant stick, a tiny mini deodorant stick of, of.
Yeah.
Rub on some black.
Those do work.
They're effective.
But again, in Las Vegas, if you leave it outdoors anywhere, that's melty, melty.
It just, it's like, like a candy bar.
It just melts.
It's just gone.
Yeah.
Even the car or whatever it's, it's all.
You need a cooler for your sunscreen.
That's it.
Like a white mask on my face, a cooler of sunscreen.
You'll be fine.
You have all those coolers with the wheels on it.
You can just pull it behind you.
You should just get, just get some, just straight up Bukkake yourself and don't even rub it in.
There you go.
That's exact.
Tin Scoop has exactly the look I'm talking about.
Oh, those principles go full baby.
I'm Bukkake myself.
That's for sure.
For $75,000.
Yeah.
We will let you powder our asses.
I'm actually wiping away my constant tears with an old t-shirt just because Keata Clumsy,
it's her favorite specific about men, is having old t-shirts around.
So.
Oh yeah.
I figured I'd collect tears.
There.
That is true.
I cleaned my shop yesterday and I was looking for rags and I used two old t-shirts.
There you go.
That were on a shelf in my shop.
That's why you keep them.
That's it.
I was walking around yesterday.
I was walking around on the strip yesterday and a fella approached me.
I was on my kind of regular circuit.
My nice, Matt just has a sock that he's now dabbing his eye with.
Yeah, that request that I switched to a sock.
Oh good.
Oh, I sent you a text about your eye.
We need a picture of your eye.
Oh God.
For what?
We need a selfie.
Yeah, probably.
Oh, I hate you.
Okay.
Anything for the pod.
That's right.
So I'm walking around yesterday and I am in front of the Harris Casino.
At the Harris Casino, they have a crosswalk there that crosses across the strip there.
So I'm waiting there.
I'm waiting for the crosswalk to change to cross over like 10 lanes of traffic that is
the Las Vegas Strip.
And I am underneath a little overhang in the Harris Casino as is my habit when I stand
there, because it has one of those air curtains, one of those outdoor air curtains.
So it keeps the hot air outside and keeps the cold air inside.
So I just stand under that and it keeps me nice and cool.
So as I'm standing there, a young man approaches me.
I would say in his mid-20s, and this has happened on occasion before, and I believe I told some
stories from Portugal where I was offered some various types of drugs in Portugal.
So this guy comes up to me and he says, "The weirdest thing to open," but then I very much
appreciated him later, because his opening was, "Hey, when you want to graduate to ski
boots, let me know."
Oh, that's a good opener there.
And I knew what he meant already.
I knew what he was offering me already.
He's offering me cocaine.
He was going to fill a ski boot with bourbon and you're going to drink straight from the
boot.
Oh, God.
But I didn't know what he meant by graduate to ski boots.
He meant you were high already at other things.
That's what graduate is.
That too.
He was like, "When you're ready to get higher than you are."
That's probably what he meant, actually, now that you say it.
He was mistaken, but that's probably what he meant.
So I'm standing there and I'm opening my mouth to say basically, "No, thank you."
And he thinks that I don't understand him.
So he goes, "Yeah, we're going to go skiing.
We're going to go skiing."
And I still can't get my mouth open.
He goes, "In the snow.
We're going to go skiing in the snow."
And then he leans in and I'm just smiling at this point.
I'm thrilled at this point.
He leans in close to me and goes, "Cocaine."
And everyone around him was like, "Cocaine."
Yes.
I was like, "I need you to do less cocaine.
I am worried about you.
I need you to do this less.
All of your friends and family are very concerned."
He's like, "I actually could have just been more direct.
No one cares, but I just love slang.
I just love to speak the street."
He had a whole thing that he just ratted.
He was like, "You want to graduate with some ski boots?
We're going to go skiing.
I mean in the snow.
Cocaine."
You need to have more faith in your metaphors, sir.
Yeah.
Clearly.
I got it.
I had you the first time, man.
I was already not interested in buying cocaine from you after the first thing you said.
But I laughed, and I gave him a smile.
I said, "I'm all set right now."
I think I said something like, "I'm all set for ski boots right now," or something like that.
And he smiled.
"O-caine-kay."
He just goes into Big Latin.
"Ud-way.
U-way.
I-lay.
U-day.
I-bay.
U-caine-ay."
I'm on Mount Fuji with a Yeti, bro.
I'm good.
I have a nasal salve in powdered form.
What?
Mood enhancer.
I was like, "I'm good, man.
I'm good."
Mood enhancer.
And he smiled.
He said, "Well, if you change your mind, I hang out right over here."
And I said, "I got you, man."
We gave each other the nice fist bump, and we parted friends.
But I have a cocaine dealer friend now.
How many guys do change their minds?
How many guys walk five steps and go, "Actually, yeah, I'll take the cocaine."
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Probably not zero.
Not one.
Yeah, it's not zero.
Hey, you want to erode your septum?
Yeah.
Huh?
Cocaine.
Ooh.
Street drugs.
Guys, I didn't mean to swipe the A-block with my PTA talk there.
Well, you did.
Thanks a lot.
We have to get down to talking about Taylor Swift and Travis Kelsey's engagement, right?
Finally.
We're late enough in the news cycle that I think the backlash against it is hilarious.
I can't believe there's backlash.
Who cares?
Have you seen the Taylor Swift haters out there, mostly hardcore right-wing people,
MAGA people, that have said Taylor Swift's career was going down the toilet so she attached
herself to a famous man?
Oh, boy.
Yeah.
That's insanity.
She made more money than anyone.
No, no, no, no.
That's just idiocy.
That's meant to be trolling.
They're not actually trolling.
I think so.
Yes, I think so.
I'm sick of living in this world where bizarro opinions matter.
Yes.
Everybody knows that Taylor Swift has billions more dollars than Travis Kelsey in her bank
account.
Right.
But I'm all for it taking up space in the news non-politically because all we're doing
is assaulted by these terrible things.
I love having non-political big news stories.
I was like, "I don't even care that much, but you know what?
I'm going to root for it and I'm going to be here for it because it just means I'm not
reading a story about Trump.
So let's go.
Let's dive in."
Yeah, it's great.
I want nothing but good things for them.
Good for them.
Hooray, billionaire people.
Go have a good life.
Paul has no beef with this at all.
I don't have any beef with it, honestly.
It's fine.
It's cute.
My wife is very invested.
I mean, I have bought several Taylor Swift songs.
I like Taylor Swift's work.
I'm not a Taylor hater by any means.
I think she's really very talented, very good.
But there's rumors she will play the halftime show and/or possibly the Sphere.
Oh yeah, yeah.
That makes sense.
The halftime show I think makes more sense to me.
Here's why the halftime show makes sense to me.
The Sphere doesn't make as much sense to me because it ties her here and she can't make
as much money in the Sphere as she can in stadiums.
Unless she charges crazy money per Sphere seat.
But they already charge crazy money per seat in the stadiums as the only person in the
three of us who has bought Taylor Swift concert tickets and has bought Sphere concert tickets,
the Taylor Swift concert tickets were much more expensive.
Actually, you have invested a percentage into their wedding planning.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I think I paid for the veil or something.
You may have paid for one or two of those flowers during the photo shoot for the proposal.
One petal of the flower, one little tiny hoop of the veil, one tiny little tiny hole.
You paid for a tiny hole, Jacob.
I paid for a tiny hole.
But the Super Bowl thing makes sense because we were talking about on chat yesterday.
The album is coming out.
The Showgirl album is going to come out in October, which means that by the time the
Super Bowl rolls around, she could be into full swing promo mode for whatever new tour
she's going to make another $3 billion off of.
Yeah.
So I mean, the Super Bowl thing makes sense just from an advertising standpoint.
But the Sphere-
The Sphere would be amazing.
For a rap standpoint, because she would have to play like 50 concerts or something for
multiple years.
I mean, she could just do a year-long Sphere residency.
Yeah, she could just park it in Vegas and just make it-
She's one of the only ones that could actually do that.
She could just do five days a week at the Sphere if she wanted to.
She really could.
Yeah.
And just sell it out and just do it that way.
She could just have a full-time job.
And then I could apply to be her sunblock applier, and I could try to spray and have her walk
through the spray and yell, "Don't touch it!"
"Don't touch it!"
Don't touch it as she goes through it.
And she'll be like, "It doesn't work!" and you'll be like, "Did you touch it?
Is it the product or did you touch it?"
You know you touch it.
You touched it.
You know who else touched it?
The following sponsor.
Today's show, Matt and Manly's Ice Cream Social is brought to you by Uncle Johnny's Super
Mega Awesome Golden Puke Bucket Emporium.
It's from Brian the Boulder Scoop in 2022.
This is Uncle Johnny's Super Mega Awesome Golden Puke Bucket Emporium.
Hey, you butthole-faced dummy.
I'm Uncle Johnny.
Uncle Johnny is here with the puke bucket.
Hey!
You want a look in it?
Better be a quarter, a shiny quarter to Uncle Johnny before you get to look inside Uncle
Johnny's puke bucket, you butthole-faced turd.
Come over here.
Let me see your face.
Come over here next to Uncle Johnny.
Uncle Johnny wants to touch it.
Your face.
Just your face.
No, thank you.
Put it in the bucket.
Put the quarter in the bucket and puke on it.
Uncle Johnny's got a million dollars.
And our hate scoop's a check out.
No!
Jacob, why are you cutting off that goal?
I don't know.
That bit was just getting warmed up.
I must have had a leave of license.
That bit was just getting warmed up now.
Clearly.
Oh, they had just been cleared for takeoff.
Uncle Johnny was going to go to some real dark places.
There was a lot of gold still to be mined in Uncle Johnny.
The voice reminded me a little too much of my real Uncle Johnny.
Triggered.
Yeah, yeah, triggered.
My Uncle Johnny, who's not really my uncle, I think he's like a second cousin or something.
Yeah.
But yeah, that was a little too close to Uncle John right there.
It's very tricky to balance that Uncle Johnny voice and not slip into full Cosby, which
I was dancing on the line.
But I managed to do it.
I was pretty proud of myself.
I just put an inspirational quote from Cosby up on my Instagram.
Oh, good.
Here, drink this.
I separate art from the artist.
Yeah.
Good.
I separate art from the Garfunkel.
Oh, so you guys can figure out whether you want Uncle Johnny there to be in the Hollywood
Squares come Scoop Fest and figure out which characters you want for that.
Uncle Johnny.
Oh, Uncle Johnny.
You get Uncle Johnny three lines, the three line character Uncle Johnny, who just basically
says Uncle Johnny has a million dollars.
But that, you know what?
And the promise is he's going to get a lot worse.
He's got three lines and a promise.
The promise of getting terrible.
Just a reminder, I'm going to be in San Antonio next week, so by the time you hear this, I'm
here Monday through Saturday, the first through the seventh with shows every night at the Magic
Saloon in downtown San Antonio.
Come check it out.
Nice.
You guys want to do a little Scoop Mail?
More than anything.
Let's do a little Scoop Mail.
Message for you, son.
Well, y'all want to hear from the Satanic Scoop?
My dearest churn migrants, I have long thought about a frustration I've heard voiced by Matt
and Jacob and also by other commentators that I probably would put in the box labeled normal.
How much you can consider a magician slash improv comic normal is left as an exercise
for the observer that you never see in sports, movies or TV shows anymore as a fictional
exercise.
You get little drips here and there like Ted Lasso or that Will Ferrell show or the upcoming
movie Hymn from Jordan Peele.
But it is an undeniable fact, even to sports ball denier like myself, that the institution
of the sports show has disappeared from the popular consciousness, at least in America.
You see, gentlemen, there is one place where the sports drama is still strong and it's
motherfucking anime.
What?
Every year brings in a new crop of stories of big dreams of athletic glory.
Like some of them like Yuri on Ice are delightfully gay.
There's even an American hand egg anime.
It's called Ice Shield 21.
And while tragically heterosexual, that is still pretty darn good.
There are racing soccer, figure skating, track and field and basketball animes, tennis and
basketball are there.
There are boxing and wrestling shows of every stripe.
It's all there, my friends.
There's even a show about girls trying to knock each other into a pool with their asses.
And it's treated as serious as heart surgery.
In this time when conventional sports ball has failed you, has failed all of us, might
I suggest taking in the zany antics of cartoon pretty boys embroiled in ridiculous melodrama,
respectfully fucking you in the face while giving you a 15 minute monologue about my
tragic backstory.
That's the Satanic Scoop.
All right.
That's a fine pitch.
Thank you, Satanic Scoop.
Those are good suggestions.
I remember back in my day when I was an old anime head getting my 18 hundreds on VHS and
whatnot.
Yeah.
There was a basketball one.
This is manga mostly.
I think there maybe was an anime for it.
There was a basketball one.
I remember the other manga that I read.
There was a big tennis one.
I read a few of those just to see.
And then I got into the, there was a manga all about the game of go, which we would call
a fellow here in the States.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
A manga all about go players and the competition.
It was interesting.
So they have never shied from going deep into obscure subjects to mine from.
And I applaud them for it.
Well, all right.
Let's go.
Let's applaud them too.
How brave.
Well done.
Thank you.
Thank you, anime.
Heroes that we don't deserve.
Oh, we got an email here from Scott.
Hello.
My name is Scott.
I think my Scoop name is Scoop Me.
No, Scoop You.
Listener since 2018 yet have never wrote in, which at this point feels weird.
Okay.
Well, I'm glad you wrote in Scott.
I have a story from my dad from a couple of years ago, which I've remembered multiple
times since and I've chuckled about each time.
So I figured I'd pass this on.
Please.
He used to get a roll and a cup of coffee from this bakery multiple times a week.
He walks in one particular morning to the lights half off and someone moaning help quietly
from the back.
Oh God.
My dad being born and raised in Queens in the seventies assumes he's walked into an
armed robbery yet feels too bad to not check out what's happening.
Lo and behold, the older woman opening the bakery that morning fell into the steep basement
while trying to put the kitchen lights on.
The best part is after my dad helps her out in the basement and into the front of the
shop, she immediately says to him, so what do you want?
Very sharply.
Amazing.
So he like helps her up and she's like, all right, now what do you want?
Yeah.
My dad confused and flustered by the situation said, huh?
To which she replied, why did you come in?
Resulting in my dad placing his normal order and paying full price as if nothing had just
occurred.
Hilarious.
She gave no fucks.
I would provide follow up, but my dad has decided to go to Duncan ever since.
I bet.
I would too.
It's not the best story, but you fellas have worked for the worst.
Thanks for the awesome comedy.
That's Scott.
Hilarious.
If I help a store connoisseur, a store owner up after having, after she has fallen into
the basement, I expect at least the discount.
I mean, just to thank you so much.
Yeah.
Maybe, maybe a donut, maybe a free donut or a, yeah.
Just say thank you.
Not even just, what do you come in for?
Thanks for helping me out of the basement.
Here's a donut.
I would have, and maybe this is strong, thrown her back in the basement.
I think you could have done one better and put sunscreen on her.
Charge me full price from down there.
Just help her apply some sunscreen, Matt.
That'd be far more favorite.
Yeah.
I'll just sort of mace her face and then let her stumble down the basement on her own.
That's really funny.
But there you go.
And there you go.
How funny.
Indeed.
Right?
And also lost a customer for life.
Lost a ritualistic customer.
Well, at least weirded one out.
I mean, he went to Duncan.
Yeah.
Like that's it.
That's not something, I bet that woman went home that evening and was like, man, I fell
down the steps.
This patron came in and helped me up.
I bet she didn't think to herself, I bet I lost that patron.
I don't think she was, I don't think she's thinking anything.
As someone who works early in the morning, my brain doesn't really kick in until about
two hours onto my shift.
Oh, you're right.
You're right, Paul.
An hour later, she's like, I shouldn't have charged him for that.
I should have given him a doughnut.
She probably, yeah, probably.
Maybe.
You're probably right.
You know, you're just kind of like going through the motions of, I gotta do this shit, I gotta
do that shit.
Oh, fuck.
Whatever.
So.
But she's gone.
He's gone.
Nope.
Yeah.
You're probably exactly right.
Oh, well.
I'll tell you what you won't be right about.
The questions in Jock vs. Nerd.
Oh, that was really, that was clever.
That was a good one.
King of the segment.
Oh, am I?
Fuck yeah.
I'm on the hunt for balls.
Explosion.
Hunt for balls.
On the hunt for balls.
Oh.
What?
We got a scooperty coming at us today from Scalawole Scoop.
He said this is a spoof, all like spoof stuff.
What did he say in his email here?
Oh no, I already got rid of the email, but yeah, he said it was all like spoof stuff.
The categories are Zazz movie spoofs, music spoofs, fake TV spoofs, and...
Spoof-a-ree.
How do you say Pope-a-ree but with spoof?
Yeah.
Spoof-a-ree.
Paul, you're up first.
I'll take fake TV spoofs for 200, dick.
My name is Jacob.
What would you rename a critically acclaimed Apple TV series if you turned it into a zombie
show about a deceased soccer coach?
The Walking Dead Lasso.
Oh, the Walking Dead Lasso is good.
What is Dead Lasso?
Yeah.
Nice.
That's me.
I'll try the spoof-a-ree for 200.
Some consider this the greatest spoof of all time, making fun of the French by making fun
of the British.
It spawned its own Broadway musical spoof named after canned meat that a rather famous
audio guy worked on.
That would be Vienna, the musical.
Spamalot.
Vienna.
What?
No.
Oh, it spawned one of the movie name, not the musical name.
Tricky.
Wow.
You got spoofed.
Monty Python and the Holy Grail.
Pretty sneaky, sis.
I got spoofed.
We got spoofed.
Spoofed and boofed.
I'll take spoofed and boofed.
God damn it, Teen Wolf.
Fake TV sports.
Fake TV.
There's no sports.
Fake TV spoofs.
Oh, spoofs.
You wouldn't need to change the name of this TV show if the Muppets took it over, and instead
of the more obvious choice of the Swedish chef used Fozzie as the lead character, Rizzo
would be hilarious as Richie.
The Bear.
What is the Bear?
Paul.
I'll try Zazz Movie Spoofs.
I'm intrigued.
Zazz Movie Spoofs for $200.
Daily Double.
Oh my God.
I wasn't ready.
I hope you were really intrigued.
This spoof franchise has almost as many films as the horror franchise that inspired the
spoofing.
David Zucker directed parts three and four with a writing assistant by Abrahams for number
four.
Scary Movie, I believe.
Scary Movie is correct.
Yay.
Which was the original title of Scream.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
It's me.
I'll try Music Spoofs for $200.
Coolio wasn't so cool about Weird Al making this spoof, but we can see why as some could
argue that it's gone on to eclipse the original song it's based on.
Even Ezekiel thinks it's a better song.
Let's see.
So let me reread the question carefully this time so I know what it's actually asking me
for.
It's asking you for the spoof, not the original.
So cool about Weird Al making this spoof.
This spoof is called Amish Paradise, which is a spoof of Coolio's Gangster's Paradise.
There you go.
There we are.
Raid the question carefully and get the answer correct.
Matt!
Are you at barn raisings often?
Fake TV spoofs.
For $600.
Already spoofed by this podcast, this Netflix series title would work as a reality show
pitting princes or princesses against one another or a real 100 meter dash to determine
royal bloodlines.
Sill wouldn't be as funny as the real series though.
Is this is so the original?
Oh, oh, I get it.
It's spoofed by this podcast, this podcast being this podcast, Matt, like our podcast.
Yes.
This one right here.
We have made fun of this Netflix series.
Yes.
It is a current Netflix series that we have discussed at length.
Quarter lengths, half lengths, full lengths, all the lengths.
Yes.
The Crown?
I don't think The Crown is a reality show.
All right.
I'll pass.
I'm missing it.
Paul!
It's the...
Oh, if Paul misses it now, it's great.
No, no, no.
It's called Race for the Crown.
Race for the Crown.
Oh, I'm dumb.
I get it now.
Yeah.
Paul!
He's just not going to get it.
We didn't need that question to determine that I was dumb, but it's a good reminder.
I'll go with Zazz Movie Spoofs.
For 400, this spoof franchise was recently rebooted and according to two young discerning
movie critics may just be the funniest movie of all time.
Move over, Ace Ventura.
That's got to be The Naked Gun.
Got to be The Naked Gun, right?
Yes.
Move over, Ace Ventura.
Oh, I can't.
I'll never make room.
That's me.
I'll try Spoof Parie for 400.
James Bond was ripe for spoofing, so it was surprising that it wasn't until the late 90s
that this character introduced us to a lot of fagina.
Felicity Shagwell, Robin Swallows, and the twins, Fook Me and Fook You.
That would be the International Man of Mystery whose name is not Maxwell Smart.
His name is definitely not Maxwell Smart.
It is...
Our Man Flint.
That's it.
His name was Q. His name was Austin Powers.
Isn't it funny how the brain just goes big holes in it?
Yeah.
Yep.
Matt, you're up.
Getting old is awesome.
It's so much fun.
Fake TV spoofs, please.
For 800, already a kind of a spoof of all the 80s entertainment we grew up with, this Netflix
series with a Stephen King tone and a title font has a character with a name that recalls
the hilarious line from the brilliant spoof, "This is Spinal Tap."
Man, I don't know.
I have no idea.
Does that go to me?
Paul, it goes to you.
Yeah.
It's "Stranger Things."
Oh, "Stranger Things."
Because it's 11.
She goes to 11.
Well, okay.
Do you remember 11?
Did you see...
I remember Spinal Tap.
Did you see that Spinal Tap played a secret show in front of the actual Stonehenge?
Yes.
Fucking crazy.
And they're coming out with a new Spinal Tap as well.
Just hesitate and cheat because people keep taping the real answers into the chat.
It's an honor system, Matt.
I don't look at the chat.
You can just close the chat, too, if you're too tempted.
Paul, you're up.
I can't see the chat.
When I share the screen, I can't see the chat.
How did you make marks on the screen?
I didn't do it.
Did Newman do that?
I don't know.
You did the Daz Movie spoofs for $600.
How would Newman do it?
Newman's walking outside in the park.
I don't know.
You did that somehow, Jacob.
I didn't do it.
Hold on.
Stop sharing the screen.
Don't come back.
I don't know what that is.
Some of the marks suddenly appeared on the screen.
The granddaddy of the spoof genre.
What now?
Why is Newman who he suspected of drawing on there?
Because Newman's name popped up when it was appearing.
Newman, you can unmute if you feel offended, if you feel attacked.
Go ahead, Newman.
Have I offended your delicate sensibilities?
Little out of left field, buddy.
Okay, so for people who are listening, all of a sudden on the shared screen, marks just appeared on it.
And on my screen, next to those marks, it had the name Newman.
All right.
I'm actively trying to mark on your face.
Damn it.
Spoof.
Oh, no.
He got spoof in my eye.
Thanks for having me.
Always a pleasure.
The granddaddy of the spoof genre.
Paul, this is your question.
This film had its own sequel and made fun of disaster films, Saturday Night Fever, From Here to Eternity, and Zero Hour.
It might encourage you to order lasagna on your next flight.
Airplane.
Absolutely.
Hell, yeah.
See, it's me.
I'll try movie spoofs for 800.
I still don't know what Zazz means.
Does anybody know what Zazz means?
I don't.
Somebody in the chat.
It might just be one of those things that this movie's got Zazz.
Got Zazz.
It could be that thing.
This Zazz classic stars Val Kilmer.
Oh, Zucker, Abram Zucker.
It is.
Okay, so it's all Zucker films.
Oh, gotcha.
Okay.
This Zazz classic stars Val Kilmer and riffs on old war films, Elvis era musicals, Blue Lagoon, and spy movies.
It all sounds like some bad movie.
Ah, you shouldn't hang me on a hook.
My father hung me on a hook once.
Once.
That and that movie, it's not Spies Like Us.
Nope, it sure isn't.
You could pass.
I know I could pass, Paul.
I know how the fucking game works, Paul.
I know what I'm able to do by the rules of the game.
I'm encouraging you to pass, that's all.
That we invented?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shit.
That is.
That's not right.
Fuck.
Again, close.
All I can think of is Spies Like Us.
Okay.
Man, I saw that movie a bunch, too.
Man.
I guess I'll pass, Matt.
Top secret.
Top secret, motherfucker.
Correct.
By the way, the same thing would have happened if I got the question.
I would have frozen.
It happens.
You struggle and pop right into my head.
That's how it works.
Matt, you got spoofs or spoofs.
Music spoofs or spoo-per-ee.
I got to gain ground on Paul here, huh?
Oh, yeah.
Paul has 2,800.
Matt has 1,200.
I have 400.
Thanks a lot, top secret.
And there are five questions left.
One daily double left.
I'll take spoo-per-ee for 800, please.
All right.
The legendary director of this film and so many classic spoofs
recently announced a much anticipated sequel.
No telling if it's going to suck or blow, but one thing's for certain,
the merchandise is where the real money is made.
The search for more money.
Spaceballs.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
This film.
Stop, stop, stop.
Mel Brooks.
Woo.
Spaceballs.
Thanks.
You saved it.
Well, the first line sounds like it's asking for the director and the movie.
It does, yeah.
Paul, you're up.
Music spoofs, please.
For 400.
This spoof.
See, Newman's name just popped back up on my screen again.
What are you doing, Newman?
Why are you messing with this game so much?
You did it.
This spoof of MacArthur Park has one of Weird Al's best videos rendered in
classic California raisin style stop motion claymation.
They certainly spared no expense.
As Jurassic Park.
Oh.
Jurassic Park is frightening in the dark.
All the dinosaurs are running wild.
Beautiful.
Yes.
Let's see.
It's me.
I guess I need to avoid the daily doubles.
So hopefully I can't win.
It doesn't matter.
Music spoofs.
800.
A fantastic reminder of grammar rules that any teacher would love.
Weird Al's Word Crimes is a spoof of the big hit that many retroactively
deemed to be a bit rapey and was considered a crime itself.
The subject of several lawsuits.
That is the classic song Long Distance.
Long Distance.
That's right.
I mean, if you read between the lines, it's pretty dark.
I have no idea.
I passed, Matt.
Grammar rules.
Teacher would love Weird Al's Word Crimes.
It's a big hit song that many retroactively deemed a bit rapey.
Scoop and Overgirl just typed Blurred Lines in the chat.
I'm going to go with Blurred Lines.
You're cheating ass.
It is Blurred Lines.
Well done, Matt.
I was going to say it's a--
Well done, Matt Donnelly and only Matt Donnelly.
The song had some growing pains.
Ah, growing pains.
There you go.
Matt, you got Spoof, Spoof, Spoof, Puri.
That's a good hint, Paul.
That was a good hint.
Just play this episode backwards and it'll make sense.
That'll be good.
It was Alan Thicke's Rapist Child.
Allegedly.
Is it my turn?
I don't know.
Alan Thicke had more than one kid.
Yes.
Eddie?
I'll take Spoof Puri, please.
For 600.
The way the amazing cast of Rickman, Rockwell, and Weaver played it so straight in this film
truly makes it an underappreciated spoofing of the Star Trek series.
Let us know if anyone in ICS ever worked in a situation similar to this film.
Oh, shoot.
This happened to me.
It's about the Jacob.
The name would be in my head right now.
I never know the name of this name.
Our whole gang went to go see it.
It was really a fun day.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody from the experience went to go see it.
I'm just stalling for someone to just type in the chat.
No, don't do that.
That's race for the crown.
There you go.
Thank you.
Also race for the crown.
I'll pass.
That passes by the game rules.
That passes to Paul.
I think it actually passes to me though.
It's called Galaxy Quest.
Galaxy Quest is it.
And Paul closing out the category.
Now I'm stuck with the double, right?
Music spoofs for 600.
Daily double.
This is it.
This is the fucking biggie.
For all 3,800 and the win.
Oh, man.
For first place or last place.
AI really took it to one of the legendary Beatles.
Oh, it's not AI.
That would be Al.
Al really took it to one of the legendary Beatles when he quite accurately spoofed this
song by writing his own version entitled This Song's Just six words long.
There's more lyrical craft in Al's version than the original.
It's I Got My Mind Set on You by George Harrison.
I Got My Mind Set on You by George Harrison.
I'm sorry, Paul.
It's Got My Mind Set on You, not I Got My Mind Set on You.
Oh, tough day.
That's a loss, Paul.
I'm sorry.
You're right.
It's a rough game, Paul.
Oh, sure.
Top but true.
I mean, it is seven words instead of six.
That's right.
That is the game.
We'll give Paul the win with 7,600 points.
Matt's gotten second with 2,800.
I've got third with 400.
Thanks a lot, Top Secret.
And that is from Scala Wall Scoop.
Thank you, Scala Wall Scoop.
If you want to send us a scooperty or a Price is Right jock versus nerd or an obelisk jock
versus nerd or just some good old fashioned scoop mail, head over to HeyScoops.com right
there on the home page.
You can do all those things at HeyScoops.com where you can also buy yourself some tickets
to Scoop Fest.
Buy tickets to Scoop Fest.
It's going to be awesome.
I saw some chats.
Jacob, make sure you're checking the messages coming through Scoop Group or the Instant
Messenger on the old Facebook.
Somebody wanted to buy an extra ticket for the barbecue for their wife.
I'm not checking anything on Facebook, but if you want to buy an extra ticket to the
barbecue, go to HeyScoops.com.
Click on it.
Buy an extra ticket to the barbecue because there are a couple of tickets on there.
There are some tickets on there.
We've expanded the barbecue tickets.
And I even told Eric the other day, we were talking about it a little bit.
I think at this point, if anybody wants to come to the barbecue, sorry, not if anybody
wants to come to the barbecue, if anyone would like to purchase tickets to the barbecue and
come to the barbecue, we'll figure out a way to make it happen at this point.
So come on down.
Scoop Fest at the end of September.
It's going to be awesome.
Yeah, it is.
I'm going to thank all the people who support this podcast.
Let's do this week in and week out.
And I'm going to thank some people who support us over on our Patreon as well.
All of these people, don't touch it!
David Peterson, David Kaye, David Gravel, David A Small, David Johnson, Dave Slusher,
Dave Hanson, Dave Serial, Darth Scooper, Darren Cunningham, Danny Olwein, Danielle Matias-Ferrer,
Daniel Loeser, Dan Martin, Dan 33, Cup of Scoop, Chris Meyer, and Cream City Scoop, baby.
The following people just got engaged to the entirety of the San Francisco 49ers.
Chris Jerg, Chris Jackson, Chris Fisher, Chris Ellis, Chris Bartschi, Chelsea Farr,
Charlie Thompson, Charles Gieshecki, Charles Eaton, Cassie Rice, Carolyn Albert, Cargo Van Killa,
Captain James T. Scoop, Canadian Scoop Crystal, Cameron Hall, Callie Ghost, C. Wick, Buster Kamikaze,
Brian Traves, Brian McLeod, Brooks Lyle, Brian Richard, Brian Maddox, aka Anarcho Scoop, and Brendan Allen.
The following people, don't, just don't make them dress up like a baby.
Greg Little, Greg DeFamer, or Craig DeFarmer, both.
Court Myers, Country Scoop, Counselor Matt, Corny Scoop, Corian Ichimura, Cone Photoscoopter,
Colton Setberry, Colleen Fisher, Coffee Bean Scoop, Coconut Time Travel, Clown on a Brothel,
Clayton Shoney, CJ McNana, Chronicler Scoop, Christy Salinas, Christopher Huff, Christopher Heyworth,
Christine Starr, Christine Elsesser, Chris Meloncon, Chris Kay. Thank you so much.
The following people fell into the basement of their small business and lay there for hours until help arrived,
and then rendered no thanks to those that hated them.
Brendan Light, Brad Martin, Bobby Becerra, Bob, Boatswain Scoop, or Bosswain Scoop,
Blue Line Scoop, and Boatswain Scoop, that's it.
Blue Line Scoop, Bill Beatty, Bike Scoop, Big Sexy, the Digital Nomad, Big Lotta Scoop, Ben Sherman Scoop,
Ben Smith, Ben Gao, Ben Dennis, Ben, Belgian Triple Scoop, and BJ Joyer.
And the following scoops definitely don't want to dress up as a baby. No!
Don't make the following scoops dress up as a baby. They'll be so mad if they have to dress up as a baby.
That's Bear Scoop, Bearded Scoop III, BB Hermit, Basecamp Scoops, Bart Funk, Bad Pirate Scoop,
AWOL Scoop, Avon Zarls, Armas Saar, Apple Scoop, Anton Jernberg, Ant Foods, Angry Face Scoop,
Angela Chan, Andy Cheek, Andrew Ostruck, Andrew Koenig, Andrew J. Hughes, Andrea Anderson,
Ameri Scott Scoop, All-Star Scoop, Alice Scoop 6666, Akshay Mysore, AJB, Adam Stickney, Adam Goff,
Aaron Winting, Aaron Boyd, Aaron, a Scoop of Root Canal, One Small Scoop for Man, the Unbanned Scoop,
We All Scream for Mark McLean, Underscore for Shaping, the Micro Scoop, and Signature Curl Scoop,
and of course, our good friend, Max! Max, who didn't get a whole lot of thank yous the last couple of months
after you upgraded. So thank you so much, Max, who I know from working in St. Louis. Super thanks.
And who is a Scoop now. So thank you so much, Max, for sticking with us all these years
after we met so many years ago at some gigs.
All right. And we'll do it for a Ranch Slug Scoop since we owe him like a year's worth of something.
That's right. Thank you, Ranch Slug Scoop. And Ranch Slug and Max both got, they both got envelopes
filled with old classic stickers from me as apologies as well.
Okay. Very nice.
All right. If you want to be thanked on air, head on over to preachingfun.com and pick a tier that fits your budget today.
[music]
Oh no! I'm dressed as a baby and there's sunscreen in my eye. Fartsinabag.biz.
Farts, farts, farts, farts, farts. Fartsinabag.biz.
That's fartsinabag.biz, that along with preachingfun.com. It takes you to our Patreon page where for as little as $3 a month,
you can help keep this show on the air. That's right. If you loved this show, this specific show.
That's right. With all of our, with all of our baby talk, head on over to preachingfun.com, fartsinabag.biz.
Join us over there today for as little as $3. You get all kinds of cool things. You get cool stuff in the emails.
You get, there's going to be pictures now. There's going to be all kinds of weird, cool things over there at preachingfun.com.
Fartsinabag.biz. It's going to be awesome.
Thank you all so much. Hey, still can buy tickets to ScoopFest, go to ScoopFest.com, buy a ticket today.
Our hotel discount, I think that period's over. I'm trying to get a response to them to see if they want to extend it.
But usually, we're going to find out. It usually cuts off and we'll see what happens.
But still, still the Orleans is a very reasonably priced casino. It's a value. It's still a value game.
But come on out for ScoopFest and we'll have you out there. And also stay safe out there.
We love you and we'll see you at the Cone. We'll see you soon. At the Cone.
Thanks for everyone joining us in the chat today. Lovely to see all your faces live and directed.
Wonderful to see everybody. Hope everybody's doing good.
[Music]
Oh, now Myra just like a little floating hand just went up my screen that said it was from Myra.
I don't know what people are doing on the Zoom chat. It's freaking me out.
This is wild. I love you, everybody. Stay safe. See you. Bye.